aber können sie dann nicht mehr sport
sprechen
[Musik]
ein seltenes naturschauspiel der
bundesparteitag der cdu in köln 1001
menschen sitzen beieinander und
langweilen sich zu tode
denn die cdu steckt in ihrer schwersten
krise die kanzlerin schmeißt den laden
die basis aber lässt sich gehen sie ist
träge und faul kurzum einfach bock los
noch mal die frage was haben sie im
letzten jahr segensreich für deutschland
getan hat
schöne frage
ich habe nicht viel deutschland getan
was haben sie im letzten jahr für
deutschland getan für deutschland
google fahren ich habe dafür gesorgt
dass die kirche sich pflege bekämpft
wird die kirche essig fliege ja genau
das ist eines der zentralen probleme
deutlich die größte frechheit als die
chefin spricht steht man sich davon also
und hinterlieger richtig genau die
kanzlerin spricht und sie verlassen den
saal
es ist betrüblich dass du nicht ein
bisschen das ist frech hallo delegierte
delegierte ja jetzt sagen verraten mal
warum sie jetzt wo die kanzlerin gerade
spricht hier draußen sind
das ist kann ich ihnen sagen weil meine
tochter gerne ich haben wollte
das ist wichtiger als wenn sie kanzlerin
spricht vom 11 sagt ja
ja aber ich würde gerne aber ich muss
auf toilette das war jetzt ungefähr fünf
minuten auf der toilette musste es so
lange sein wenn es vor allem zwei
minuten auf der leute und es war wichtig
die kanzlerin uns ein wenig getrübt sein
stil wird jetzt sparen haben sie ihren
laden nicht im griff dass also einer
querschießt und dann jetzt auch noch
realisieren will vertrag nochmals also
diese frau deutschland unserem zimmer
setzen kandidat für mich sind gut wir
können sogar noch ein paar brauchen dann
kann man freie abstimmung ja aber können
sie dann nicht mehr sport sprechen
ja es ist schlimm um den parteien körper
bestellt gut dass da wenigstens ein paar
komiker die laune heben bin ja auch
nicht mehr der jüngste ja aber ich habe
mal dazu wie sie gesagt hat war mein
gegner anwälte jetzt im bundestag da
müssen noch ein paar ingenieure mehr hin
nichts sagen palim palim berlin berlin
palim palim palim palim palim palim ich
bin tatsächlich hier für die gute sache
machen sonst ja was denn hier los
dabei hätte ich wäre auch für jede
andere partei gekommen
aber es macht sinn die nld hatte er
liebe linksparteien eckart von
hirschhausen ist buchbar ab macht's
führung soll unbezahlbar dagegen die
gottgleiche erhabenheit eine angela
merkel selbst die parteijugend ist ihr
erlegen
gibts nix an dieser frau was natürlich
wäre ich bin jetzt kein mann wartet mit
diesen kritiklosen abgegangen ist die
cdu dem untergang geweiht
wir haben uns alle damit zurück ins
studio
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
[Musik]
hersteller
wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß und sie
töten - wollt dann abonniert jetzt den
kanal
was zur hölle ist mina hersteller
[Musik]